[Musique]
1973 année du premier choc pétrolier la
france dont les centrales électriques
fonctionnent principalement au fuel
n'est pas épargné l'heure est donc aux
économies je fais appel et nous faisons
appel avant tout à sept vertus
traditionnelles paraît-il du peuple
français quel esprit d'économie et pour
l'esprit d'économies qui mieux que le
ministre de l'économie
face à la pénurie de pétrole valéry
giscard d'estaing a une idée il indique
par exemple que nous ferons ont conduit
à fixer une heure de printemps l'heure
d'été pour mieux faire coïncider le jour
et la journée et pour mieux faire
coïncider le jour et la journée il faut
donc avancer son horloges d'une heure et
ça pour le porte parole du gouvernement
c'est la promesse des économies
d'électricité
est ce que concrètement vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi en avançant leurs
d'une heure ont réussi à faire des
économies à tous ces monstres à partir
du moment où en avançant d'une heure les
gens se couchent ont une heure plus tôt
le soir pendant l'été de ce seul fatiha
une consommation électrique qui se
réduit d'autant avec cette mesure le
gouvernement espère économiser 300 mille
tonnes de pétrole par an mars 1976
l'heure d'été entre en vigueur les
français avancent leur réduit et
l'événement national inspire le
journaliste roger gicquel au temps
suspends ton vol après l'heure c'est
plus l'heure avant l'heure c'est pas
l'heure qui veut voyager loin ménage sa
montre bien entendu tout le week-end
l'actualité sera branché sur le cadran
électrique ou non qui vous fera vivre
dimanche une journée de 23 heures mais
qui finalement ne gagnera pas grand
chose sur le temps que nous avons à
vivre ni sur ce que nous faisons du
temps que nous vivons et un mois plus
tard selon le gouvernement les premières
économies sont déjà visibles monsieur
syrota est-ce que déjà les premiers
indices que vous avez confirme ce que
vous espériez ainsi conscient des
économies d'énergie absolument si l'on
examine les courbes de consommation
horaire d'électricité on constate qu'il
y a une différence par rapport à ce
qu'on obtenait antérieurement et cela
correspond au fait que l'on ne consomme
plus l'électricité tout à fait de la
même façon c'est à dire eh bien c'est à
dire que l'heure de lumière naturelle on
a le soir remplace une heure d'éclairage
artificiel et par conséquent diminue la
consommation d'électricité d'autant la
conclusion est claire on recommencera
sans doute l'an prochain
et ça fait quarante six ans qu'on
recommence mais aujourd'hui cette mesure
permet tel toujours de faire des
économies oui répond l'agencé de
l'environnement et de la maîtrise de
l'énergie le passage à l'heure d'été
permet une baisse de la consommation
d'électricité de 351 kilowattheures par
an soit la consommation annuelle
d'environ soixante dix mille foyers
[Musique]